el futuro de venezuela se juega dentro y
fuera de sus fronteras este lunes
comienza una vista pública en la corte
suprema británica para dirimir quién
tiene la legitimidad para reclamar las
reservas de oro venezolano que alberga
el banco de inglaterra el banco central
de venezuela bajo la junta rectora
designada por maduro quiere recuperar en
torno a mil millones de dólares en oro
aproximadamente el 15 por ciento de las
reservas de oro del país el problema
radica en quién es el presidente
legítimo ante la justicia británica el
pasado octubre el tribunal de
apelaciones británico falló en contra de
wide hoy la junta designada por él para
dirigir el banco central de venezuela
según el tribunal el gobierno británico
no reconocía de forma inequívoca al
opositor como presidente este lunes el
gobierno de reino unido- reiteró su
postura de reconocer a juan guaidó como
presidente legítimo del país
latinoamericano
el gobierno del reino unido tiene
derecho a decidir a quien reconocer como
jefe legítimo de un estado extranjero el
reino unido- reconoce a juan guaidó como
presidente de venezuela y en
consecuencia es el único individuo al
que se le reconoce la autoridad para
actuar en nombre de venezuela como su
jefe de estado según el equipo jurídico
de wide o el gobierno utilizará el oro
para despojar al país de sus riquezas a
favor de la corrupción el banco central
de venezuela afirma sin embargo que es
necesario para paliar la crisis
económica y sanitaria ante las
acusaciones opositoras el gobierno pide
que los recursos los gestione el
programa de las naciones unidas para el
desarrollo